et l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 173 de Monsieur Philippe
Bas madame la ministre de la Culture et
de la Communication
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre ma question concerne
le Mont-Saint-Michel
nous assumons au Mont-Saint-Michel un
projet très important qui consiste à
rétablir son caractère maritime
et pour ce faire la diggroute qui a été
construite au 19e siècle
va être supprimée et remplacé par une
passerelle sous laquelle la mère pourra
avancer et ainsi l'insularité du Mont
Saint-Michel sera rétablie ce beau
projet qui
concerne un élément du patrimoine
universel que nous avons nous Français
en dépôt et malheureusement quelque peu
ternis par la construction d'un gay à la
sortie du Mont-Saint-Michel qui va
atteindre une hauteur de 7 mètres 30
alors naturellement quand on arrivera au
Mont Saint-Michel on ne verra que le
Mont Saint-Michel c'est quand on
ressortira du Mont-Saint-Michel qu'on
aura face à soi une sorte de barrière de
béton qui sera constituée par ce gay ce
gué va donc défiguré les abords du
Mont-Saint-Michel alors pourquoi le
construire on a invoqué depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant puisque ce
projet de rétablissement du caractère
maritime du Mont-Saint-Michel est en
cours depuis près de 20 ans on a invoqué
des impératifs majeurs de sécurité
l'évacuation de nos visiteurs si à marée
haute l'un d'entre eux a besoin de
secours
urgent cette raison justifierait
du point de vue de l'administration un
point de vue dont je reconnais qu'il a
été constant jusqu'à présent que l'on
puisse
à sec évacué des visiteurs du
Mont-Saint-Michel par sur lequel
pourront se poser des hélicoptères les
associations de défense du site de
nombreux architectes et la population
qui
est familière du site depuis des années
pour ne pas dire l'héritière de cette
population qui a accompagné la vie du
Mont-Saint-Michel depuis des siècles
considère que ces arguments de sécurité
peuvent être aujourd'hui être réexaminés
et l'objet de ma question n'est pas de
vous dire de renoncer immédiatement à la
construction de ce gay qui va défigurer
pendant des décennies au moins les
abords du site mais de vous dire Madame
la Ministre notre souhait que une étude
soit conduite pour essayer de
mettre en place des alternatives qui
soient aussi respectueuse de la sécurité
de nos visiteurs que la construction de
ce game et qui n'aurait pas
l'inconvénient de défigurer le site
merci mon cher collègue madame la
ministre
je vous prie d'excuser l'absence de ma
collègue Aurélie Filippetti qui regrette
profondément de ne pas pouvoir répondre
personnellement à cette question parce
que c'est une question essentielle sur
laquelle la ministre a tenu justement à
se pencher très vite et elle a pris en
considération la question que vous avez
vu aviez adressée d'ailleurs le courrier
que vous lui avez adressé le 25 octobre
2012 à la suite de ce courrier elle vous
a alors elle vous a répondu le 25
octobre de votre courrier du 18 octobre
2012 donc elle a fait diligence et elle
a pris des dispositions pour que l'objet
de la question soit étude de votre
question soit étudié avec la plus grande
rigueur elle me charge de vous donner
lecture de la réponse donc qui vous est
adressée parce que en rappelant que
depuis 10 ans depuis plus de 10 ans
l'état
affirme avec constance un objectif de
sécurité des visiteurs et des personnes
qui travaillent où habitent sur le mont
le projet de l'établissement du
caractère maritime du Mont-Saint-Michel
prévoit la suppression de la digue route
reliant actuellement le rocher au
continent de manière permanente et son
remplacement par un pont passerelle
prolongé par une jetée ainsi que la
suppression des parkings situés au pied
du mont il est prévu un terre-plein
d'accès qui accueillera les visiteurs
arrivant du continent par des navettes
ou à pied ce que vous avez décrit compte
tenu de la connaissance précise que vous
avez du site
le ministère de la Culture de la
commission vous indiquez d'ailleurs dans
son courrier qu'il envisageait de
solliciter un nouvel arbitrage quant à
la hauteur du gué qui permettra de
limiter l'impact visuel du terre-plein
une réunion interministérielle s'est
déroulée le 5 décembre 2012 et à l'issue
la côte de 7 mètres 30 a été confirmé
par le Premier ministre parce que cet
auteur constitue un compromis entre les
considérations de sécurité et la
dimension esthétique selon les
expertises effectuées en matière de
sécurité tout nouvel abaissement de la
côte aurait pour effet d'augmenter la
durée d'insularité du Mont laquelle
reviendrait également plus souvent et de
surcroît pour des périodes de grandes
fréquentation touristiques les moyens de
secours que vous évoquez sont
performants en période normale mais il
faut tenir compte des situations
dégradées ainsi ni les véhicules
amphibie en hélicoptère ne pourrait
toujours selon ses expertises procéder à
un évacuation de masse en période
d'insularité la prise en compte de ce
risque a donc justifié le maintien de la
côte de 7 mètres 30 donc madame la
ministre vous fait savoir qui n'est
absolument pas insensible à la question
de l'esthétique et donc de la vue et moi
personnellement j'y suis aussi
particulièrement sensible c'est
incontestablement le cas du ministre de
l'éducation nationale aussi nous aurions
aimé pouvoir vous satisfaire en
abaissant la digue vous la souhaitiez à
6,70 je crois il me semble et puis plus
bas encore plus bas encore mais je suis
sûr que vous partagez les préoccupations
matières impératif de sécurité voilà la
décision donc qui a été prise
merci madame la ministre monsieur bas
merci madame la ministre à vrai dire
votre réponse de me surprend pas
mais nous aurions souhaité nous l'avons
demandé à de nombreuses reprises que les
expertises ne soient pas toujours
conduites par les mêmes c'est-à-dire par
l'administration qui n'a aucune raison
de se désuger depuis maintenant plus de
10 ans qu'un arbitrage dans le sens que
vous avez indiqué a été rendu et le
souci que j'avais en posant de nouveau
cette question était d'obtenir du
gouvernement qu'il veuille bien et à
vrai dire ça ne lui coûterait pas grand
chose de le faire essayer d'objectiver
davantage sa réponse qui est un peu une
réponse que nous recevons comme une
réponse d'autorité en voulant bien
confier à une commission indépendante le
soin de réexaminer cette question car
aucun d'entre nous naturellement ne
voudrait prendre le moindre risque en
matière de sécurité mais pour autant les
conséquences pour les conséquences
d'ordre esthétique tellement graves que
cela nous paraissait mérité à tout le
moins un examen complémentaire avant de
lancer les travaux qui sont maintenant
imminent je suis sûr madame la ministre
que vous relèverez directement ma
préoccupation madame la ministre de la
Culture dont c'est la mission de
préserver ce joyau du patrimoine
universel
merci